it's Joaquin Phoenix a spoiled movie
star or is he pulling our collective
legs once again during an appearance on
Jimmy Kimmel Live Phoenix was presented
with an outtake from Joker in which he
appears to go on a profane rant much
awkward joking between Phoenix in Kimmel
ben ensued and we're not sure exactly
what to make of this for so many reasons
Phoenix and Kimmel were engaging in easy
banter the star appeared engaged and
relaxed and everything was going fine
until Kim will appear to drop a pretty
awkward bombshell specifically he showed
a clip from a supposed I'll take real
courtesy of Joker director Todd Phillips
that didn't exactly show the most
flattering side of mr. Phoenix in the
clip Phoenix gaunt and partially made-up
is attempting to tap into his character
Arthur Fleck aka the Joker
unfortunately this proves difficult
thanks in small part to the constant
whispering of a crew member named Larry
although it's not heard it's implied
that a man means Larry accuses Phoenix
of being a diva by waiver friend to him
as cher which acts a star even more
[Music]
Phoenix then declares that he simply
can't carry on and walks out of the
frame when the interview resumes Phoenix
appears profoundly embarrassed adjusting
his tie and appearing to start sweating
so as movies get intense to see her a
lot of people in a small space in there
trying to find something and I was
supposed to be private he says that last
part somewhat jokingly and throughout
the audience's laughing along giving him
the benefit of the doubt it's rather
disarming and a little weird to see such
a massively talented actor set
completely off his access looking
confused and mortified unless that is
you're familiar with this month's long
piece of performance art which Phoenix
staged roughly a decade ago in October
2008 Phoenix made the surprising
announcement that he was quitting acting
to focus full-time on music rap music to
be exact he made good on his promise to
become a rapper early the following year
with a baby performance in Las Vegas
that was equal parts unintentionally
hilarious and actually painful for the
remainder of 2009
Phoenix publicly insisted that he was
done with acting while apparently
attempting to barrel forward with his
rap career
remember that famously bizarre awkward
the Late Show with David Letterman I was
at the beard mall there well as it
comfortable is it itchy is that are you
pleased with it I'm ok with it now you
make me feel weird about it not long
after the interview word leaked out that
has starred enlisted director Casey
Affleck to direct a documentary
following his transition from movie star
to dope MC in 2010 the film titled I'm
still here was released and shortly
thereafter the ruse fell apart it had
all been a giant hoax one that Phoenix
have perpetuated in public with a
straight face for over a year he
returned to acting in 2012 with a
brilliant performance in Paul Thomas
Anderson's the master and recently he
stated that the whole thing was a gag
between himself and Affleck that got
seriously out of hand considering the
extreme lengths to which Phoenix was
willing to go to put one over on his
fans the Jimmy Kimmel Live bit seems
well a bit suspect
why would Phillips blindside his star by
sending the talk-show host such an
embarrassing I'll take why would Kim or
drop it on Phoenix without warning him
in advance at the end of the day the I'm
still here experiment proved beyond a
shadow of a doubt that there are no
actors quite so willing to yank the
chains of their audience like Phoenix
and it turns out the profane outtakes
screen than Jimmy Kimmel life was a hoax
as the actor's publicist told
Entertainment Weekly that it was a quote
joke I'll take and that's a good thing
to work in Phoenix seems like a pretty
well-adjusted guy so we had a fingers
crossed that he wasn't as big of a jerk
as his character Arthur Fleck inevitably
turns out to be but he assumes the
identity of the Joker and the Clown
Prince of Crime next a big-screen outing
check out one of our newest videos right
here plus even more looper videos buy
your favorite stuff are coming soon
subscribe to our YouTube channel and to
the bail so you don't miss a single one
[Music]
you
[Music]